hey little guys my name is Machado and
welcome back to my people of clock
series this is going to be a really
quick episode in which I'm just going to
based answer the question what is the
difference between a struct class in C++
the last time we talked about classes in
general and we had a bit of a basic
introduction to what classes actually
work you guys haven't seen that video
check it out there'll be a link to the
description below as well as like some
kind of weird annotation I think what
are they called cards they'll be a card
somewhere on the screen but basically we
have these two terms in table bus but
struct which is short for structure or a
class and they might appear to be sort
of similar and a lot of people are a
little bit confused about what the
differences are exactly when you should
be using a struct when you should be
using a class this video is going to
address all that so the difference is
this there is basically non there is one
small difference to do with visibility
so last time when I talked about how we
had a class having its members private
by default which meant that if I was to
do something like this however I did not
declare this as public then we would get
an error because you can see that it
would tell us that the move method in
the player class is inaccessible because
it's in Marshall's private default
meaning only other methods inside this
class can actually access that move
method which is why we have to write
public here if we want to execute this
code because of course we're calling
player don't move outside of the player
class and that's essentially where the
difference comes in a class is private
by default so if you don't specify any
kind of visibility modifier like I did
here if you don't just get rid of it and
you don't specify anything at all
the default is private however was the
struct the default is public that is the
only difference between the structs in
the class technically and you can see
over here in our code we get an error
because again move is inaccessible
however if I change this to safe struct
player that solution that has changed
the work class construct that's all I've
done this is all fine now and if I
actually did want something to be
private I would explicitly have to write
private and then of course that takes us
back to the same error that we got with
a class that is the difference it's
incredibly simple that's really all
there is to it however instead of just
putting up a two-minute video
just mentioning that I want to kind of
talk about how we might be defining
differences between those two words
because like they might not technically
have much of a difference however the
usage in code is actually going to
differ
the only reason struck really even
exists in C++ it's because of the
backwards compatibility that it wants to
maintain with C because C code doesn't
have classes it does have structures
though and if we were suddenly to wipe
out this whole struct keyword entirely
then we would lose all compatibility
because the compilers the superclass
compiler wouldn't know what struct was
of course you could fix that pretty
easily by just using a hash to find so
we could write something like hash
define struct class right and then
suddenly what that's going to do is
replace all of our struct with classes
so in this case even if code might look
pretty pretty simple
I can pilot you consider suddenly we get
that same error telling us no can be
accessed inside a class even though
we've used it we use the web structure
because the course is replaced structure
with the word class and then maybe yes
you can get that kind of compatibility
between C code and C bustle code back
because ideally you should be able to go
into C code and replace the works trucks
with class and then make it public and
then that would be it that would be the
end that there would be no more
different in that actual scenario so
then the difference kind of semantically
and how people see it come down to more
or less the usage if there is no
difference when do I use trucks purses
class do I use a struct if I want all of
my members to be public and I don't want
to have to write the web public is it
really that trivial and yes by the way
it is actually that trivial and so
because of that people have kind of come
up with their own definitions for what I
think astruc should be and what I think
a class should be however there is no
really like there really is no like
right or wrong answer it's kind of up to
your style of programming so this is my
video let's talk a little bit about my
style of programming and where I might
use each type so I like to use struct
whenever possible when I'm basically
talking about plain old data or p OD
basically where i'm talking about some
kind of structure which just represents
variables a bunch of variables and
that's really all isn't there for a
great example of this might be something
like a mathematical vector class if I
were to come over here and I wanted to
make some kind of structure which just
held two floats together such as a back
to I might define it as a struct and
just have my x and y floats
why because fundamentally this back to
class or struct or whatever you want to
call it is that to structure is just a
representation of two floats
that's what it is at its core it's not
supposed to really contain a massive
amount of functionality like a player
class might where it might be having it
might like a player class might have a
3d model it might handle all the
rendering code for that 3d model it
might be handling like how the player
moves around the map and taking in
keyboard input and all of that there's
just so much functionality there right
whereas what this is it's just two
variables and we proved them literally
just for the reason of making our code
easier to use that's all that we've done
and of course that's not to say that I'm
not going to be adding methods to this I
absolutely will I might add a method
called add which takes in a null evac'd
too and then adds it to the current
vector by doing something like this
right but again what I'm doing here is
I'm just manipulating these variables
I've just added a function that will
manipulate those variables but at the
end of the day I'm still just talking
about those two variables now of course
if you were really to break it down and
think about it
really hard then you could argue that at
the end of the day even the player class
is just manipulating those variables
however there's a bit of a difference in
terms of design because we're talking
about something that is massively
massively more complicated the other
scenario is inheritance I will never use
inheritance with structs if if I get to
the point where I'm actually going to
have an entire class hierarchy or some
kind of inheritance hierarchy I'm going
to use a class for that because again
inheritance is something that's adding
another level of complexity and I just
want my structures to be structures of
data that's it and additionally to that
if you try and mix those
for example you have a class called a
and then a struct called B which
inherits from a some compilers will give
you warning telling you that you're
inheriting from a class but you're a
struct and there are some other kind of
minor differences but again that is
warning secondly your code will still
work it's just a bit of a semantical
difference so those are kind of my
reasons for using instructors in the
class if I just want to represent some
data in a structure I will use a struct
but if I've got an entire class filled
with functionality like a like a game
world or a player or something that
additionally might have inheritance and
all of these all these systems I'm going
to use a class and again that's how I
personally differentiate between those
two types that's how a lot of people are
seen in the industry differentiate
between those two types but again if
there is technically no difference apart
from that visibility you can use a
struct wherever you can use class that
they're going to work the same way
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
just look at that like button of course
you can follow me as well on Twitter and
Instagram links will be in the
description below if you really like
these videos and you want to support
this series and see more then you can
support me on patreon block comport -
the shadow and additionally to just
supporting me and making sure that I can
make more videos you'll get access to
early draft as well as a discussion
board where we talk about what actually
goes into this video so if your
interests in that check out the link in
the description below
hey Fiona come forth - Jenna and next
time we're going to continue on our
journey as to what classes are going to
talk about stuff like inheritance and
look at some examples of existing code
to see how you should be structuring
your puzzles how you should be writing
them and how we can use them in our code
I'll see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
[Music]